فيلم مؤتمر الدولي الذي عقد في موسكو مع
حركه طالبان في العام 2021 وفي سبيل
الاعتراف بحكمتها تعاهدت الحركه بحمايه
حقوق المراه الافغانيه التي اقرتها لها
الشريعه الاسلاميه لكنها ابقت على هامش
كبير في ترجمه ذلك وظل الغموض اقتنف
تصريحات مسؤوليه الحركه في تحديد شكل حياه
المراه الافغانيه تحت سلطه الطالب ان في
نسختها الجديده
بان حركه طالبان باتت نسخه معتدله
ومتسامحه الا انهم بالعوده الى اعداد مجله
الصمود لسان الاماره الاسلاميه القديم
منها والجديد يستطيع المهتم بكل يسر
وسهوله ان يطل على ترجمه حركه طالبان
لمعنى حمايه حقوق المراه الافغانيه
وايديولوجياتها في فهم الشريعه الاسلاميه
فيما قال كتبها عماد الدين الزرنجي في
مجله صمود وقبل السبع سنوات في اغسطس 2016
بعنوان المراه الافغانيه هدف المؤامرات
حذر من محاولات الحكومه الافغانيه السابقه
وبمساعده من الدول الاخرى رفع معدل برامج
المنح التعليميه للمراه الافغانيه مستشهدا
بتصريح رئيس الجامعه الامريكيه في كابول
اللي عبر عن ساعات بان عدد الفتيات بشكل
نصف عدد الشباب فيها طبعا تحذير مجله
الصمود وهي المجله الرسميه التابعه
للاماره الاسلاميه جاء مباشره بعد تنفيذها
عمليه ارهابيه استهدفت الجامعه الامريكيه
في كابول والتي على اثرها اوقفت الجامعه
برامجها التعاونيه مع برنامج الوكاله
الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه الخاص بتعزيز
المساواه بين الجنسين في البرامج الوطنيه
ويعرف باسم روماد وهو برنامج مهني بانه هو
بالمراه الافغانيه وانفق عليها اكثر من 89
مليون دولار بغرض تحسين وضع 75
الف امراه افغانيه من خلال تنميه القيادات
النسائيه وتعزيز دورها في القطاع الحكومي
والخاص والمجتمع المدني وقال عماد الزرنجي
هذه مشروعات تعليميه عديده تهدف لتربيه
امهات المستقبل تربيه علميه تجعلهن
مستعدات ان يكون ساعدا اقوى للغرب في
تطبيق اهدافه الشيطانيه واعتبر عماد الدين
ان جميع اسباب الضلال المتوفره في المعاهد
والمدارس والجامعات التي تعتني بدراسه
المراه وما قال اخر بعنوان اراجيل تحرير
المراه الافغانيه حضر فيه كاتب ثاني من
وسائل اشاعه الفحشاء الموجوده في
افغانستان من السينما والمسارح والنوادي
ووسائل الاعلام من الاذاعه والتلفزيون
والصحف المجلات والاثار الخطيره من
التعليم المختلط في جميع المراحل ومنعم
اللباس الاسلامي على حسب على حد يقول صاحب
المقال ومن المهم ان يشير هنا لان موقف
طالبان من مدارس الفتيات لم يتوقف عند زمن
سقوط اماراتها في العام 2001 ولكنه استمر
بعد ذلك وهو ما اكد هذا مجله الصمود تحت
عنوان ضرب الركيز الشعبيه للجهاد بتاريخ
فبحسب كاتو التحقيق فان اولى خطواتي
طالبان خلال وجود القوات الامريكيه كانت
احراق مدارس الفتيات باعتبارها هدفا
جهاديا وقال كانت مدارس الفتيات مستهدفه
بشكل اكبر ومنع الاهالي بناتهم من ارتياها
فهدفوا الاحتلال ابراز نماذج جديده للنساء
على النمط الاوروبي والمتمردات على
الاسلام من طراز المراهقه
ملاله يوسف زايد من منطقه القبائل التي
منحت جائزه نوبل للسلام لتكون مثالا
للنساء القبائل في التمرد على شرائع
المقابل رجعه واكد كاتبه التحقيق وهو
مصطفى حامد مؤرخ تنظيم القاعده ومن محل
اقامته في طهران اهميه دور المدارس
الدينيه في المح على المفاهيم الجهاديه
وتقاليد المجاهدين الافغاني المتوارثه
وقال من الشعب ياتي المجاهدون وتاتي
الاموال وتاتي المعلومات والتعليم الديني
هو فقط الذي حافظ على المحتوى الجهادي
لحركه الطالبان فهل المراه الافغانيه
اليوم هي المسؤوله الوحيده عن تقرير
مصيرها وهل صحيح ان طالبان ليست المشكله
الوحيده امام تحصيلها لحقوقها وكيف وباي
طريقه ستؤدي طالبان الى تدهور الاوضاع
الاجتماعيه والاقتصاديه والسياسيه لهؤلاء
النساء انا هدى الصالح وهذا برنامج جماعه
للاجابه على هذه الاسئله وغيرها معنا من
الرياض الاستاذ الله نور السلاب وهو كبير
المستشارين للمجلس الاعلى للمصالحه
الوطنيه حياك الله الساده
احنا موضوعنا عن قضيه تعليم المراه
الافغانيه من هو وزير التعليم العالي
افغاني ووزير التربيه والتعليم اذا
معلومات عن الشخصيه هذه من ميزه حركه
طالبان عندما تعين شخصا ما في منصب ما لا
يعلنون عن اي سيره ذاتيه له وياتي مرسومه
وفرمان كما يسمونه ويكون فيه اكثر من 30
شخص 40 شخص وتم تعيين فلان وفلان وفلان في
المناسب الفلانيه لا توجد هناك اي سيره
ذاتيه ماذا كانوا يعملون خلال 20 سنه
الماضيه اين درسوا ماذا عملوا ما هو
تاريخهم جغرافيا اعمارهم من اين انطلقوا
من اي ولايه
لا يعلنون عن اي شيء فقط الاسماء
ويجب على الناس ان يتعاونوا مع هؤلاء وزير
التعليم العالي همم يكتبون ما اسمه شيخ
الحديث كانه اخذ دوره علميه في الحديث
الشريف وعلمه
واحد من المشايخ الكبار ودرس هكذا مرور
الكرام مره على كل الاحاديث الشريفه التي
هم يدرسون في مدارسهم
همم ممكن يكون عمره 45 سنه او 40 سنه
لانهم لا يذكرون شيئا وانا بحثت عنه بكل
همم الصفحات الرسميه للدوله لا توجد اي
سيره ذاتيه لاي وزير وهكذا فجاه ياتون
بشخص يعينونه في منصب معين ويقولون للناس
تعاونوا ما هؤلاء طب بالنسبه لوزير
التربيه
السابق كان قليل من المعلومات موجوده انه
ينتمي الى ولايه اورزكان وعاش ايام الجهات
في مدارس باكستانيه ولكن انما جاوب
بالوزير الجديد وعزلوا الوزير الاول همم
قالوا انه كان امام مسجد في ولايه ما ف-
لا توجد السيره الذاتيه اصلا انا بحثت عن
سفر رسميه للدوله التي موجوده في السير
ذاتيه لكبار الشخصيات الدوله مكتوب هنا
اسماء اشخاص فقط لا توجد
سابقه
ولايته ولا نسبه ولا شيء واين تلقى علومه
مع من درس في اي مدرسه درست وهكذا فجاه
ياتون بشخص وهي مثل مفاجات همم يفاجئون
بها الشعب الاخباريه
وزير التعليم العالي ههه عندما قال بان لن
تتراجع حركه طالبان عن قرارها في منع
الفتيات من التعليم حتى لو اسقط الغرب
قنبله همم نوويه وقم بلاد الرياح كيف تشوف
هذا التصريح هذا التصريح للقنبله الذريه
كان عندما يجتمع مجلس العلماء في قبل
السنه في كابول واكثر من 2500 عالم
اجتمعوا اقترحه بعد النقاط على زعيم
الحركه انه ياخذها في الحسبان عندما يدير
هذا البلد فعندما جاء
امير المؤمنين حسب الجماعه
الى كابل والخا ختامه الى مجلس العلماء
المكون من 2500 شخصيه وكان ظهره الى الناس
ووجهه الى القبله المشرفه
فالقى هذا الكتاب وقال لن ارضى لضغ العالم
ولا للامم المتحده ولاء امريكا ونحن نريد
ان نتعاون ونتعامل مع العالم ولكن اذا
يدعون علينا شروطا لن اقبل اي شروط ولو
القى علي قنبله ذريه ولنا اخاف من احد قد
لفت انتباهي لما ذكرت بانه هو معطي ظهره
لمن كانوا حاضرين من العلماء طالب همم
الافغان وعلماء طالبان ملالي طالبان لماذا
هل هو حقيقه هبه الله خانزادا ام هناك
شكوك انه يعني مش هو هذا العام هذه الحركه
هم لا يحبون التصوير هم لا يريدون ان يقف
امام الاعلام لا يريدون ان يواجه الشعب
اصلا هو هذا هو همم الشرح الصحيح
لتصرفاتهم ولكنه همم جاء وتحدث في هذا
الاجتماع وتحدث في قندهار مع بعض الشخصيات
واتحدث لكبار رجال الاعمال في افغانستان
ولا احد راى وجهه الصحيح الحقيقي
المنشور في الصحافه سابقا لشخص ما ان هذا
هو ال- اا البلاء
فيها بيكون بنفس الهيئه بنفس الطريقه
بيستمعين
قبل الاذاعه الوطنيه وحتى لو يذاع من قبل
اذاعه التلفزيون افغانستان فلا تكن هناك
صوره فاياتي صوت فقط ويتحدث ويلقي ختامه
كالقى اكثر من خمسه ختابات اليوم وبمناسبه
العيد بمناسبه التعامل مع الغربي بمناسبه
التعليم وهمم وكل ختابات يعني لا يوجد
فيها مضمون قوي حتى يبشر بالخير للشعب
الافغاني وان يثق الناس بقيادات طالبان ان
هؤلاء عندهم نيه لتغيير النظام لتغيير
المنهج للحكم
امر مقتل وفاه الملا عمر هو الزعيم المؤسس
الحركه الطالبه كانت الحركه يعني اخفت هذا
الخبر او هذا النبا اللي مدري كم سنه يمكن
سنتين ثلاث سنوات همم عن العامه الى انفضح
حتى فضح هذا التنظيم داعش هل تعتقد ان هبه
الله اخذ زاد لا زرار قيد الحياه في مثل
هذه الحركات التي كل شيء فيها مجهول
الهويه لا يمكن التاكد من اي خبر فيها
بشكل قوي وقاطع لان لا احد يعطيك
المعلومات الصحيحه غير الذي اسس هذه
الحركه غير الذي انشا هذه الحركه غير الذي
اوصلها الى السلطه هم الوحيدون الذين
يعرفون حقيقه الاشخاص الموجودين فيها ومن
هو على اي منصب وما هو علمه وما هو تاريخه
ابغى اسالك في هناك طرح امريكا يقول ان
المشكله المشكله في المجتمع المراه في
افغانستان
لا يقتصر على طالبان بل بالقيم اللي
بشتونيه وان طالبان هو ابن المجتمع
ويستطيع ان يعني
يغير بهذا من خلال القيم الاسلاميه وانه
هو خير حليف
لتفكيك او محاربه التقاليد البشتون
فهل هذه تعتقد انها قراءه صحيحه ام انه
طالبان هي بالاساس من تعزز التقاليد
البشتونيه او قانون الشرف اللي بشتونه
هذا الكلام الى حد ما صحيح ولكن عندما كان
فانسان عام 1960
فقبل 60 سنه ما كان احد يرغب ان يرسل حتى
ابناءه الى المدارس الشرطه تاتي وتاخذ
الابناء بالقوه تدخلهم في المدارس غير
البنات الاولاد الذكور ايضا كانوا لا
يرغبون في الذهاب الى المدارس هذا الكلام
قديم جدا خلال 60 سنه الماضيه عندما بدات
الحرب والناس ذهبوا الى بشاور ومنهم ذهبوا
الى ايران ومنهم من ذهبوا الى الغد طبعا
كلها هؤلاء يتعلموا اكثر من سته ملايين
وسبعه ملايين افغاني خرجوا من الوطن
وتعلموا في المدارس في الدول المجاوره
وتطور التعليم وتغيرت المفاهيم همم لتعليم
اصلا نظره الشاب تغيرت للامور فالمره الان
تعمل المراه تتعلم المراه تخرج الى الخارج
بمنحه دراسيه وتدرس لوحدها في الدوله
بعيده عنها
يعني همم حتى بعد في ال- في الحكومه اشرف
غنيم السابقه
واللي قبلها انهم ما بوصل العدد كان نسبه
يعني عاليه بانه يقبل المشاكل كثيره اللي
همم لهذه النسبه القليله لان ادم وجود
مؤسسات في الولايات البعيده عدم وجود
مدارس في تلك الولايات كافيه المواصلات
كانت غير متوفره والناس تعود الان ما
يذهبون كيلومتر واحده الى الاقدام سابقا
كانوا يذهبون للمدارس خمسه كيلو مترات او
سبعه كيلو متر الى الاقدام ويرجعون في
الظهر الان عدد المدارس كثير تغيرت همم
وضعيه التعليم في افغانستان خلال 20 سنه
كانت هناك اكثر من 13000 مدرسه للدوله
ويدرس فيها اكثر من 13 مليون طفل من بنين
وبنات هناك 400,000 خريج من الثانويه
يلتحقون بالجامعات الجامعات الحكوميه كانت
تستوعب اكثر من تقريبا 150,000 طالب في
الجام الرسميه
والدوله قدمت اكثر من 20 الف منحه دراسيه
الى اليابان والهند وايران ومصر والدول
العربيه مثل الامارات والسعوديه
والاف منهم درسوا في جامعه امريكيه مرموقه
وفي اوروبا
فالبيئه التعليميه متغيره تماما عن ما
يتحدث عنها الاجانب والامريكان لان هذه
قصص قديمه هم درسوها في كتبنا والان
يركزون عليها ويعطونها اهميه اكثر ان كل
تصرف طالباني ممكن له اثر سلبي سابق او
انه كان ناعمه
تجاه المراه الان الاخلاق البشتونيه
للمراه معززه مكرمه الناس يحترمونها في
الولايات لا توجد اي مشكله المراه تخرج من
بيتها لوحدها تذهب الى مزرعتها تذهب الى
اقربائها تذهب تشتري لها اغراض لوحدها
باي شكل من الاشكال ولا تلبس البرقع
الكامل نحن عندنا كبير هو اللبس الافغاني
الاصلي هذا البرقه ايضا دخيل المجتمع
الافغاني الذي يغطي الوجه الجسم بشكل وكان
واحد داخل في تابوت هذا ليس من الثقافه
الافغانيه اصلا فخلال هذه السنه ال 60
الماضيه يعني كان هناك تطور في كل جانب
يعني نحن الان نعاني من هذه النقاط التي
تاتي من المؤسسات غربيه التي اشتغلت وانتم
حدثت من مشروع بروموك الذي كان يهتم
بتطوير المراه ويعطائه الفرصه المشروع هذا
اخذته زوجه الرئيس السابق الدكتور اشرف
الافغاني على عاتقها عندما اصبحت هي
السيده الاولى في افغانستان ولي اول مره
في تاريخ افغانستان يؤسس مكتب خاص لزوجه
الرئيس نحن الرؤساء السابقون حتى جلاله
الملك ما كان هناك مكتب خاص الملكه
الافغانيه ما كان هناك مكتب دار محمد حتى
ايام الشيوعيين الذين كانوا منفتحين اكثر
من بقيه الرؤساء الافلان
كارمن وحفظ الله امين وان محمد والدكتوره
نجيب الله لم تكن هناك مكاتب خاصه لزوجات
الرؤساء اصلا بينما جاء اشرف غني وزوجته
لبنانيه وهي مسيحيه تحكم افغانستان لاول
مره عن تاريخ زوجها هي التي اقترحتني يكون
لها مكتب مستقل لاداره شؤون المراه في
افغانستان وانها طلبت ميزانيه كبيره من
مكتب المساعدات الامريكيه اليو اس 8 وهم
اعطوها ميزانيه كبيره جدا لتطوير المراه
وهي وعدت بتوظيف 75,000 امراه خلال خمس
سنوات القادمه من حكمها ولكن ما كانت تدري
ان ادت 15,000 امراه في افغانستان لا توجد
هذا العدد الكبير من النساء حتى يتوظفنا
في الحكومه لان في ذلك الوقت كانت اعداد
الخريجات خليل جدا وحتى لو كانت هناك
خريجات عندما تتزوج كل سيده افغانيه معظم
ازواجهم لا يسمحون للمراه ان تعمل لان
زوجها يعمل وتعيش معززه مكرمه ومستوره
الحال في بيتها وكل مقامات الحياه اليوميه
متوفره لها فلا تحتاج ان تشتغل اصلا فلهذا
المراه فشلت في توظيف 75,000 سيده هي وظفت
بعد خمس سنوات من حكمها 54 سيده ومن هذا
العدد ايضا 30 من تلك السيدات قلنا ان نحن
نعرف السيده الاولى ولكنها ما ساعدتنا في
التوظيف نحن نتوادثنا من تلقائي انفسنا
ومشروعه البرومور قد فشله في تطوير المراه
الافغانيه لان هذه المشاريع التي تاتي من
الغربيه لها فتره زمنيه محدده كل مشروع له
مده زمنيه وميزانيه معينه وشركات معينه
يجب ان تتولى هذا الامر
بانه كان هناك فساد كان في هناك ادم يعني
تصرف همم يعني نقول انه حكيم في همم يعني
صرف الاموال لهذا المش- همم
كود من كل وزاره عندما تعلن معظم الوزراء
كانت لهم شركات مقاولات كانت لهم مؤسسات
غير حكوميه وهم الوحيدون الذين يعرفون من
مواعيد المقاولات ومواعيد منح تلك
المشاريع للشركات فهم كانوا همم الوحيدون
يحصلون على تلك المشاري هذا نوع من الفساد
الفساد الثاني ان ال- ال- الناس الذين
كانوا يتعاونون مع الدوله ويتعاملون مع
الدوله من مراجعين للوزارات المختلفه ايضا
كان هناك فساد يعني لا احد يستطيع ان ينكر
وجود الفساد المالي اما ان نسقط النظام
بالكامل من اجل الفساد مالي في تلك الدوله
وناتي بنقابه تراويش جديده لي يحكموا لنا
نظام اسلامي نظيف بالمره ويكون هو النموذج
يحتذى به هذا لن يحصل لان الفساد موجود
حاليا مكتب الجوازات في كابل لا يمنح
الجوازات لمن لا يتفاعل قيمه الجواز ب
1000 الى 2000$ وبقيه الناس ينتظرون شهور
طويله حتى يحصلون على جوازاتهم كل الدوائر
الفساد قائمه لم يتغير انما كنا في السابق
نقول ان النظام هو النظام عميل لامريكا
ويستلم مليارات الدولارات من المساعدات
وانه لا يتم فيها الا كل شيء بمشور
امريكيه حاليا امريكا خلال السنه الماضيه
كانت ترسل شنط ب 40 مليون دولار اسبوعين
الى حركه طالبان لجي بمن تذهب هذه الاموال
يجب ان نسال ويجب ان تكون هناك شفافيه من
قبل طالبان يعلنوا اننا حصلنا على ثلاثه
مليار دولار في السنه 250 مليون دولار
شهريا تذهب الى جيوغ قيادات طالبان يجب ان
يعلن للشعب
عن طريق شركه الى كابول وهم يقولون نحن
نقولها من ال- من المطار البنك المركزي
ومن البنك المركزي نحطه في حساب في بنك
افغانستان الدولي في حساب خاص بيجيء بمن
يجب ان تكون هناك شفافيه كامله هذه
الضرائب التي يجمعونها من الناس ويقولون
اننا زودنا الضرائب والماليه ومن ايام
السابقه ولان النظام كان فاسد وما كان
يعلن بشكل شفاف ان اييي كيف حصل والاموال
واين راحت انت الان يا مولانا تعال قدم
تقريرك المالي لهذا الوطن لهذا الشعب الذي
هو مسكين لا يدري من الذي يصرخ في هذا
الوطن طيب
الولايات المتحده خرجت من افغانستان تماما
انا شخصيا ارى انهم لم يخرجوا انا ارى
انهم غيروا المقابل في العمليه السياسيه
هم كانت لهم اتباع معينه في المنطقه كانوا
يريدون من الحكومه الافغانيه تصرفات معينه
همم امتيازات معينه لامريكان والرئيس
الافغاني لانه له علاقات حسن الجوار مع
الدول الافريقان الثاني ما نفذ الخطه بشكل
مطلوب من قبل امريكا
18 شهرا مع طالبان في الدوحه كانوا ماذا
يناقشون هناك يعني حركه نحن نقاتلها وهي
تقاتل وفجاه قررنا نحن نجلس مع تلك الحركه
ونتفاوض نتفاوض على ماذا انت عندما جئت
الى
من قبل يعني
الان نحن نحتار نسال منه يا امريكا انت
عندما جيت في 2001 هل وقعت اتفاق ما هي
شخص ما هل استاذنت من احد هل اخذتي موافقه
من الشعب الافغاني هل الحكومه الافغانيه
او اي شخص بعد انجلس الرئيس او عندما
اجتمع مجلس القبائل ثلاث مرات هل هم
صادقوا على وجودك في افغانستان لا عندما
تنسحبين لماذا تتوقعين اتفاق الانسحاب مع
غالبان واقعيها مع الحكومه التي كانت
موجوده في كابول التي كانت حكومه دستوريه
جهه تاريخ قنوات مشروع السفاره الامريكيه
اليوم في كابول هل هناك معلومات انه هناك
اعداد من الامريكان ما زالوا موجودين في
السفاره تقريبا
[موسيقى]
الى 700 شخص ماذا يفعلون هؤلاء
امريكا هم موجودين فيها وكل هذه الرحلات
التي كانت في كل هذه الرحلات التي كانت
تقوم باجلاء الافغاني للخارج كانت تقويم
من مطار مزار شريف ولماذا اصلا نحن نقوم
باجلائي الافغان لماذا يجب يخرج هؤلاء
بهذه الاعداد الكبيره من الوطن لماذا نترك
الوطن لاشخاص غير مثقفين غير علميين غير
متخصصين البعض بيرى ان السياسه تعني
التعامل مع الحقائق على الارض او الواقع
طيب همم وبشوفوا انها المواجهه العسكريه
مع طالبان يعني لا يمكن ان تجدي نفعا فيها
هذا
الاتفاق على ما بين الولايات المتحده
وهكذا الطالبان على اساس انه همم يعني ان
تتخلى عن علاقتها بتنظيم القاعده مقابل
توقيع هذا الاتفاق انه مقبول ومنطقي
انا استغرب انما امريكا بكبريائها وعظمتها
وبي مؤسساتها الدبلوماسيه والعسكريه
والاستخباراتيه والماليه
تاتي في النهايه بعد 20 سنه تجلس مع نقابه
الدراويش وتقول لهم تعالوا نتفق على صيغه
معينه انكم
تستلمون الحكم في كابول وبعدين تقطعون
علاقتكم بالقاعده اي منطقه في هذا اي
قاعده طالبان بنفسها همم مشكله طالبان
بنفسها خطر طالبان بنفسها ما عندها خطه
اداريه اغتاليه سياسيه
يعني خلال سنوات
لم تسيطر على ولايه واحده لمده اسبوع في
افغانستان خلال 20 سنه عندما كان الجيش
الافريقي لوحده يدافع عن الوطني لماذا نحن
اجبرنا القيادات الجيش الوطني الافغاني ان
يسلم الولايات الى قيادات طالبان ونجلد
كلها 3 من الجندي من اسلحتهم بمخطط امريكي
طبعا تم تجريد هؤلاء من السلاح وتسليم
افغانستان الى طالبه برايك هناك من يعني
يرى بان هناك جناح متشدد وجناح معتدل في
حركه الطالبان مثل تقريبا
رؤيه اوباما في ايران بان هناك جناح
الصقور وجناح الحمائم هل تتفق مع هذا في
داخل حركه الطالبه اكيد حركه الطالبان
الان في المقام الاول هي مشكله من اربعه
اجنحه
وابنه ومن لا يعقوب الذي هو يراس وزاره
الدفاع حاليا واخوه وزير الاشغال العامه
في الحكومه الحاليه جناهم الله بطل
زعيم الجماعه وجماعه اختار محمد منصور
الذي كان بعد من عمر زعيم الانتقاليا تم
اغتياله في عمليه لطائره بدون طيار وجماعه
جلال الدين
الحقاني وزير الداخليه
ابن فستاني انس حقاني واخوه همم هاجي خليل
الحقاني الذي يراس وزاره الشؤون عوده
لاجئين في افغانستان وعنده اكثر من نصف
الحكومه الان بيد جماعه حقاني والنسف
الحكومه بيد جماعه القندهاريين عموما
فهؤلاء ايضا ما بينهم تنسيق كامل انما
تقرر جماعه معينه شيء متطرف الجماعه
الثانيه تعارده جماعه حقاني التي كان
الناس يخافون منها اكثر في اثبتت ليون
اكثر مع الشعب الافغاني لانها تعرف القيم
الوطنيه القيم القبليه تتعامل مع القبائل
بشكل مرتب وتفهم لغه القبائل اما اهلك
دهار فعندهم هذا النوع من الغرور ان نحن
مؤسسي اصلا ويجب الكل يسمع كلامنا ونحن
القياده عندنا فيجب ان تسمعهم كلكم يا
شباب فانستان الان الخلاف على التعليم
تؤيد التعليم
التعليميه او الخارجي بشان حقوق المراه
بيثير الغضب الحلق الداخل في الداخل
الافغانستان وان الافضل ان تكون الجهد
والعمل من الداخل الافغاني امم يعني وكان
المجتمع الافغاني هو من يقود نفسه الى همم
الحداثه بشكل الذي يناسبه هل تتفق مع هذا
هل هذا ممكن
الكل يثق في المؤسسات الدوليه لان عندها
اليات الضغط معروفه وتستطيع ان تضغط على
اي حكومه في اي منطقه ان تغير من سياساتها
الداخليه طبعا الدول التي معترف بها من
قبل الامام المتحده من قبل المجتمع الدولي
من قبل المؤسسات الدوليه ويكون هناك تعاون
دوري مع المؤسسات الدوليه فهي تستمع الى
اراء تلك البلدان الى ارات تلك المنظمات
الدوليه التي تتعامل معها طبعا حاليا الان
لا يوجد هناك اعتراف على الحكومه لم يعترف
بها حتى الذي رباها باكستان لم يعترف بهذه
الحكومه لانها تستحي ان تقدم هذا النموذج
بها ان احنا دعمنا مثل هذه الجماعه ذهبت
منعت التعليم منعت العمل منعت يعني قيدت
الحياه في افغانستان واا نحن نعترف بها
فهم انفسهم لم يعترفوا
بوليدتهم في افغانستان
لا تبالي اصلا احد يعترف لم يعترف لان
هؤلاء يحكمون مزاجهم العقليه
والمستوى الثقافي والعلمي والاكاديمي
والاجتماعي لمازن قياداتها هذه الحركه هم
حياتهم الاجتماعيه هذه كلهم اولويه مع
بعضهم استقامه مع بعض عندهم مساجدهم عندهم
حياتهم اليوميه وهم في راحه تامه في
افغانستان لا يبالون ماذا يجري في الخارج
وماذا سيحدث للشعب الافغاني
حقوق المراه الافغانيه هي المساله
الافغانيه محليه يعني مش المفروض انها
يكون المجتمع الدولي والمجتمع الخارجي هو
من يتدخل فيها نحن عندنا همم مشكله اخرى
نحن عندنا السيدات التي
يعيشنا في القرى وفي الولايات وفي
المديريات البعيده طبعا لا يبالينا ماذا
يجري في الحكم وما عندهم اي علم همم
همم ماذا يجري في الوطن ومن يحكم وكيف
يحكم لانهن عايشات في قران
وداخلهن ثابت عندهم مزارع وعندهم ثروه
حيوانيه وعندهم دواجن وعندهم اكله مبشرهم
مضمون سكان كابول يختلفون تماما عن بقيه
الولايات العاصمه لا توجد فيها حياه
اقتصاديه نشطه لا مساء ولا عمل ولا مؤسسات
كبيره لتوظيف الناس ولا تجاره ولا املاك
وعقارات لهؤلاء سكان كابول حتى يترزق من
تلك العيدات
همهم ان تكون هناك وظيفه ثابته مستمره
مستدامه وان ياتهم داخل فالزوج يشتغل
وزوجته تعمل وبنته تعمل وابنه يعمل فاذا
همم واحد منهم فقد وظيفته واحد او اثنين
فقط
ياتي الضغط المادي على العائله فلهذا
السكان الكابل اسواتهم اكثر صرخه من
الاصوات في الولايات ولانهم بقى لوحدهم
نساء الولايات
وقفنا مع هذه الحركه لتحرير المراه او
لاخراجها او لمنهي هل حقوق والتعليم لان
النساء في الكره لا تبالين اصلا لهذه
القصه فسكان كابل هم المضغوطين لوحدهم
مساكين وهم الذين يخرجون في مظاهرات
ويخرجون ويبحثون ان فرصه عمل لانفسهم حتى
يترزقوا من وراء تلك الوظائف فاهلك اقول
هذا واحد من الاسباب الرئيسيه لان لا
يزيدون ساده اكثر لان بقيه الولايات التي
تعيش فيها اكثر من 70% من الشعب الافغاني
لا يبالونه اصلا ما وقفوا ما هؤلاء في
كابول فالكابل هذه العائلات التي يخرجن في
المظاهرات اكثرهن ما عندها رجال ما عندها
شخص يعول همم يعول الاسره فهذه الاسره
تحتاج ان تعمل بنفسها فعال الدوله ان تسمع
اولا اراء الشعب تجلس معهم ثم تقرر شيء
معين وتستطيع ان تعمل فيها تعديلات لا
يمكن نحن نغلق المؤسسات للتعليم العالي
لان كانت فيها شبهات حول الاعمال
الاخلاقيه او هناك الرزيله تمارس في هذه
الجامعات بالمؤسسات العلميه انت كدولك
حاكم كمشرع تستطيع ان تمنع تلك الاشياء
رغم ان البعض يشوف انها جلسه سنه و14
اشهر الا ان قررت مثلا الفتيات اللي هم ما
يذهبوا الى الجامعه بسبب الاختلاط او زي
او بعض المناهج يعني البعض يشوف انه كان
بامكانها يعني تنهي هذه المساله فيها شهر
وتفرض زيها وترغي المناهج اللي هي تشوفها
انها كانت لا منهج الاماره الاسلاميه
وحتى ال- همم الموضوع الاختلاف يعني كان
بامكانها حلول منها مثلا تعلم عن بعد نحن
نقول لهذه الحركه انت تقولين ان الجامعات
كان فيها اختلاف وانها كانت غير امنه
للبنات طيب المدارس بالمره
سيدات يدرسنا الحارسه امراه والمبنى
المستقل
وليست بجوار مدرسه البنات اي مدرسه للبنين
لم يكن هناك اي احتكاك بالبانيو لماذا
اغلقنا تلك المدارس لماذا منعتم البنات من
التعليم الثانوي
لا يوجد هناك منطق ولا عقلانيه ولا دليل
ولا عذر شرعي عندهم لمنع بس انهم ينتقمون
من الشعب الافغاني
مع حركه الطالب بالنيابه عن الولايات
المتحده كان مقالها في مجله انت همم
انترناشونال اندرس همم وهي همم السيده
شيرلي بنارت
وهي امريكيه يهوديه من اصول النمساوي
وهي مسؤوله او مؤسسه لمركز
فتحت مركزها ايضا في الدوحه
مقالها بعنوان المراه الافغانيه هي
المسؤوله عن تقرير مصيرها طبعا مقال طويل
ذكرت فيه ان جهود الولايات المتحده في
تحقيق مكتسبات للمراه الافغانيه كانت
كبيره من منها خالد الدستور الافغاني
ترسيخ حقها في المشاركه السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه تحفيز بناء
المدارس وايضا المهاج على النساء اللي
بيئته من الارياف والقرى للدراسه في
الجامعات في كابول وايضا البرامج
التدريبيه
للنساء الافغانيات خلال هذه السنوات وتقول
ان اليوم انه الدور الدور على بعد هذه
المنجزات كلها اللي حقيقه الولايات
المتحده خلال هذه السنوات انا الدور يقع
اليوم على المراه الافغانيه نفسها وان
النساء الغربيات لم ياخذوا حقوقهم همم في
الحقوق المراه
والمساواه من همم من همم دوله خارجيه او
ان ترسل احدى الدول جنودها لتحقق هذا
للنساء بالكافه احنا نظلنا حتى انهم وصلوا
الى ما هم عليه اليوم واا يعني قالت بان
على النساء ان يتناقشوا مع ال اا مع
الافغان ومع حركه الطالبان وبحث هذا
الموضوع واننا طالبان ليست مشكلههم
الوحيده بل انا
التقاليد البشتونيه هي المشكله الاكثر
تعقيدا بالنسبه للمراه الافغانيه وانه
يعني طالبان يعني قد تكون حليب لهم لي همم
يعني التخلص من هذه القيود او الاعراف
البشتونيه اللي يعني تقيد المراه
الافغانيه بحكم انه معرفتهم واا دراستهم
للتعليم الاسلامي والشريعه الاسلاميه وذكر
ضربت مثال لقانون الشرف البشتوني وانا
ابغى اسالك اذا هل هناك ما يعرف بقانون
الشرف البشتوني بمساله تزويج القاصرات
الصغيرات اهداءهن لاخرين او وعد بالزواج
بالفعل انه يعني كيف تشوف مقال او ما تطرح
زوجه
مايا خليفه في هذا الاطار
اولا هذه السيده وزوجها طبعا زوجها رجل
اكاديمي كبير جدا واا
الشخصيه سياسيه بارزه دبلوماسي ومفاوض
واوصل افغانسان الى هذا اليوم هو كان
مستشار الرئيسان ولي اكثر من 40 سنه له
تاريخ في قضيه افغانستان المشكله ان ال-
ال- ال- المؤسسات الغربيه تنظر للمراه
كانها فرد مستقل
في افغانستان المراه ليست فرد مستقل المرض
المراه داخل في عرض لشخص اخر هي اما زوجه
للشيخ معين اما ام لشخص معين اما اخت لشخص
معين اما بنت لشخص معين لا توجد امراه
لوحدها في افغانستان كامراه وعندما يتم
التعامل معها بهذا الاسلوب فيكون هناك
دليل نقول انهم اييي ضد المراه او ان هناك
اعمال عنصريه ضد المراه لا افغانستان لا
توجد فيها مراه لوحدها ما عندها اقرباء ما
عندها عائله عنصر من الاسره الافغانيه
الموجوده فا الان عندما المراه لا تحصل له
حقوقها الكثيره لان عائلتها لا تساندها في
هذا الشيء انها تقف لوحدها في الميدان
وتصرخ وتناضل وتخرج في مظاهرات ضد النظام
ماء ولهذا هي فاشله
وهي القادره
كلها الان فاقول المراه ليست
مستقل كما في الغرب في عندما تكون عمرها
18 سنه تستطيع ان تعيش لوحدها فتصرف
لوحدها تدرس لا تدرس تذهب تعمل لا تعمل
فكل اعمالها مستقله من قبلها هي اما في
افغانستان لا هي الى ان تتزوج هي مسؤوليه
الامن المعروف الاسره
العربيا ايضا جاءت وقالت لا يستطيع احد ان
يكره المراه بالزواج بشكل اجباري من شخص
معين مقابل المال مقابل هناك شيء في عرف
الافغاني يسمونه الورد هذا الورد هو
المبلغ غير المهر الذي يسجل في الورقه
والذي لا يعطيها في النهايه للمراه اصلا
هو المبلغ الذي يؤخذ من قبل البنت او
اخوها شخص من عائلتها ويزوجونها الى شخص
عمره 70 سنه وهي عمرها 17 سنه فهذا الشيء
كان من الاعداد السيئه في النظام القبلي
الافغاني ومازال قائم في بعد الولايات
ولكن تقريبا ايضا منعته في الاوراق
والحكومه الافغانيه السابقه منعته في
الدستور ولكنهما زال قائم ومستمر
بانها طالبا تستطيع ان تنهي هذه
افضل من مولالي الموجودين في القرى
والارياف يعني
الافلان يحتاجون الى حكم الرجل الواحد حتى
يكون الرجل اللي يمنع مثل هذه الاعمال نحن
لا نستطيع ان ناتي برجل دكتاتوري من اجل
يمنع شيء ثم نحن نواجه معه مشاكل اخرى في
بقيه الامور يجب ان يكون هناك نظام تشاوري
يجب ان تكون هناك مؤسسات من قبل العلماء
من قبل الشعب الافغاني من زعماء القبائل
لتكون هناك ما زالت يعني الشيء الاهم من
كل هذه القصص التي نحن نتحدث عنها المشاكل
يجب ان تكون هناك حكومي شرعيه يجب ان تكون
هناك مؤسسات دستوريه يجب ان يكون هناك
نظام يستشير الشعب الذي يحكمه نحن هنا
الان رجل مجهول الهويه جالس في مدينه
مجهوله في مسجد مجهول لا نعرف عنوانه لا
نستطيع ان نرى وجهه لا نستطيع ان نتواصل
معه لا هو يخرج للشعب الافغاني وهو يحكم
افغانستان هذا الكلام في القرن الهادي
والعشرين غير منطقي وغير مقبول وغير
مهذب وغير متمدن
النساء بان يطلبوا تدخل المجتمع الدولي في
موضوع حقوق المراه
طالما انها الاتفاق الذي وقع مع طالبان لم
يكن فيه بمشاركه من المجتمع المدني ولا من
النساء ولا من الحكومه الافغانيه
ان يحل هذه الالغاز الموجوده بين الحركه
وبين الشعب الافغاني الحركه يجب ان لا
تكون متطرفه مع شعبها وان تعتبر نفسه
نازله من همم من القمر ونحن نازلين ان
المريخ وعندنا خلافه لا ارض لشخص اخر نحن
كلنا من هذا الوطن من هذا الشعب من هذه
البيئه يجب ان الحكومه تكون ممثله للشعب
في كل النواحي يجب ان هي تقوم بحل مشكلات
الشعب الافغاني نحن الان نعاني من مشاكل
جمه لا توجد وظائف لمن تخرج من الجامعات
من الرجال هناك اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين مدمن
للمخدرات هناك مليون طفل يعانون من سوء
التغذيه في افغانستان هناك الاف المعوقين
والذين بتلت ايديهم وارجلهم في الحروب
السابقه هناك الاف الناس نزحوا من ولايه
الى ولايه بسبب الحروب السابقه هؤلاء
يحتاجون الى سكن الى اعاده الى اوطانهم
نحن مشاكلنا نتجمع الدوله يجب ان تجد حلا
استراتيجيا طويل الامد لهذه المشاكل وبهذا
الاسلوب الدجل والشعوذه واللف والدوران
والغش والخداء والكذب والنفاق لا يمكن ان
ندير الدوله باكملها لمده اطول الان حكم
سنه ولا يوجد هناك مخطط عام لهؤلاء ان
يروحوا للشعب الافغاني
هذا هو اسلوبهم انا اراه ان هؤلاء يحكمون
من سنه ونص حكموا سبع سنوات قبل المره
الماضيه خلال كلها سنين ما تعلموا من
تجاربهم السابقه ما تعلموا من العالم ما
تعلموا من نفس البنجاب الذين هم درسوا في
جامعاتهم ومدارسها وينتقل الى كابل هنا
دينهم يختلف من الدين الذي كان في اسلام
اباد كان هناك يجلسون مع النساء يناقشون
معهن القضايا الان وزير التعليم عندما ذهب
الى الاسلام وبعده جالس مع كل سيدات من
مجلس الشيوخ لماذا لا يجلس مع سيدات وطنيه
لماذا يطعن في شارع فيهن في وطنهم هذا
ليسوا اسلوبه افغاني ليس اسلوب همم بشتون
الاصلي ليس مهذبا يجب ان يتعاون مع شعبه
وينظر له نزلت
الاعجابتوني همم ايش موقف في الاكاديميين
سواء في داخل افغانستان او خارجها من
الاكاديميين تخصصات علميه
واخرى يعني سياسيه وادبي وغيرها من حركه
الطالب هل هم مؤيدون لها بحكم انتماء
العرقي ذاته
اي تاييد من اجل العراق الناس ينظرون الى
تصرفات اعمال الحركه هم الان واحد من كبار
الاكاديميين وهو الدكتور بروفيسور في
جامعه كابول وعنده قناه التلفزيونيه كتب
مقال طويل عريض وشرح فيه كل نقاط الضعف
لحركه الطالبه خلهم تعليم المراه تعليم
البنات
والفرس العمل ولا تتركونا احد لان يتنفس
في وطنه ويكون في كل وظيفه ملا ياتي يكون
هو الوزير هو الوالي هو المدير لمنطقه
معينه هو المتصرف في كل اعمال الدوله هذا
ليس من من من من من اخلاق الشعب يعني
طالبان لا تمثل همم
لو نجمع كل القيادات لحركه الطالبان
والجيش والشرطه والامنيين وكل المليشيات
التي تقاتل وعندها اسلحه هؤلاء لا يمثلون
مليونين شخص من اربعين مليون شخص معناه 5%
من الشعب يعني باي حق انتم تمثلون هذا
الوطن
طيب
حركه طالبان شل
المكون اللي فيها هل هم جميعهم بشتون هل
هم يعني همم
الهزاره وهؤلاء الان ي- همم
يدركونا انها هؤلاء ليس لهم مكان في قياده
طالبان لان لا احد يسمع كلامهم اصلا
[موسيقى]
غربيون ومراكز دراسات غربيه بان همم يؤخذ
قيادات طالبان بجوله يعني سياحيه قال لي
عدد من الدول الاسلاميه على راسها
اندونيسيا ماليزيا وتركيا واطلاع على
تجربتها
بحقوق بالذات بحقوق المراه همم
ايش رايك في من يصور قيادات حركه طالبان
بانهم
معزولون وكانهم في كهف غير مطلعين على هذه
التجارب
التجارب الاسلامي همم وكيف تشوف ان بنفس
الوقت منى تظهرين اسلاميين يعيشوا في قلب
الحضاره الغربيه هم يؤيد موقف طالبان
اليوم من الغاء او ايقاف تعليم الفتيات
ليس هناك
للعامل الديني والفكري السياسي الضيق
للملا والمولويه في افغانستان هو السبب
الوحيد لهذه الاعمال التي نراها هناك عامل
استخباراتي
فالعامل الرئيسي ليس فقط
على نفسه انه همم ابن بيئته الضيقه
هذه الجماعه ما جاءت من فراغ الى هذا
الوطن لم تبقى 20 سنه دون دعم خارجي
عسكريا لوجستيا مادين كان وراها شخص هل
يعقل ان نقول ان كل المولويه جالسون في
مساجدهم وكل واحد في قريته قرر ان يحارب
امريكا لا كانت هناك جهه استخباراتيه
جالسه تدرب وترهل وتمول وترسلهم الى
القتال الافغانستان
نفس الوقت لبعض يشوف انهم كانوا خلال فتره
همم يعني حروب ومعارك وانهم محاربين
وفاررين ومش مطلعين على هذه التجارب يعني
ممكن البافي جبال الكهوف تراباره
هؤلاء كلهم كانوا جالسين في اسلام اباد في
كراجي في كويتا في بيشاور كانت عندهم
عقاراتهم عندهم تجاراتهم وعندهم تعاونهم
مش كل الذين لن يحكمون كابل كانوا في
المعركه مش كل الذين الان يديرون الوزارات
ويراسونها كانوا محاربين في افلام النساء
ما كانت تصل الى 10,000 شخص الان هناك
50,000 شخص
الدوله من اين جاءوا كلهم جاءوا من
المدارس الفنجابيه في قناتي في بيشاور في
اسلام اباد يعني لا يوجد هناك شيء ان
هؤلاء ننقلهم الى ماليزيا سيتغيرون نعم
هؤلاء عاشوا عاشوا سنوات في الدوحه هل
تغيير لم تكن هناك سيدات في الدوحه الم
تكن هناك قناه الجزيره تعمل معهم مقابلات
من السيدات
وجالسات في القنوات التلفزيونيه لم
يتعودوها ولا في تركيا لم يجلسوا مع
النساء في باكستان ولكن انا اقول ان هذه
الجماعه لا يمكن ان تتعلم شيئا لان العامل
الاستخبارات هو الذي يدير العمليه هو الذي
ياتي بالفراميل هو الذي يكتب التقارير
المله الكبيره المله الكبير جالس مع
الاستخبارات الدوليه ولا ياتي باي قرار
انفرادي مولانا راى شيء في رؤيته وفي
الصباح اثر الفرمان لا هناك جهات دوليه
جالسه وراءه هم يكتبون يعمل كذا غير كذا
الغي هذا قدم هذا اخر هذا هؤلاء ما عنده
علماء يكتبوا لهم دستور سنه ورقه يكتبوها
ليكون هو المنهاج لهذه الحركه في
افغانستان هؤلاء الان العلماء باكستان تقي
عثمان الذي كان شيخهم في كراسي هو يرسل
لهم رسائل كل يوم تهذب يا شباب تعلموا
تمدنوا قلت لكم المراه تشتغل كل المراه
تعمل كل مره تتعلم
العلماء في الهند ايضا يقولون لهم انتم
اساليبكم غير اسلاميه الازهر الشريف قبل
يومين اصدر فتوى انه هؤلاء يسيئون الى
الاسلام وانهم لا يفهمون مقاصد الشريعه
الاسلاميه اصلا العلماء في المملكه لا
يؤيدونها هؤلاء
كلهم
يا اخي غير
التعامل مع الشعب الافغاني اتركهم يتنفسوا
في وطنهم يعني هل هناك شيء افغاني اسلامي
بالمره وهم لا يتعاونون من العالم
الاسلامي انا اثق ان هذه الحركه لن تبقى
لاكثر من خمس سنوات في الحكم حتى لو طالت
لان الشعب سن- بنفسه سيكون بالذهب اذا
استمر في غلق المدارس اذا استمر في
الجامعه
عازله عن السلاح بالمره وحرب روسيا لعشر
سنوات وسختها الروسيه سقطت الانجليز قد
سقطته الامريكان وهؤلاء هل سيبقون بهذا
الاسلوب اللي يحكموا هذا الوطن يجب ان
يتهذب ويجب ان يغير اسلوبهم ويجب وينظر
الى مطالب الشعب الافغاني الشعب الافغاني
يريد العمل يريد الحياه الكريمه يريد
العيش في وطنه بسلام وامان وان لا يتدخل
احد هم الان يمنعون الناس حتى يفتحون
لتبيب الاسنان الشعب الافغاني لا يستطيع
ان يقول ما بداخله يعبر لا يستطيع ان شايف
الصحافه القنوات التليفزيونيه الموجوده في
كابل كلها ممنوعه من النقاش لاي عمل سياسي
ممنوع من من من من همم شارح السياسه الغير
عقلانيه لهؤلاء فانما تكون الدوله كلها
دكتاتوريه بهذا الشكل والحكم المطلق لفرد
مجهول الهويه اصلا يجب ان يطلع للعالم
تعال يا اخي عندي انما تكون امير المؤمنين
المؤمنون مشتاقون لرؤيتك تعال اطلع اليهم
و- وسلم على شعبك اذهب الى الولايات تخاف
من المال انما تقول لا اخاف من القنبله
الذريه والتخاف من طائره بدون طيار يطلع
يا اخي
الهويه نعم مادام الرجل لا يطلع الى العلم
لا سيرته الذاتيه موجوده لا عنده هويه
افانيه ولا احد يعرف عن تاريخ يجيء
جغرافيتي اين درس في اي مدرسه كان عمره
هذا مولانا ماذا اقول لهذا الشخص
شكرا جزيلا اسمح لي ابغى اختم معك الحلقه
صراع المراه الافغانيه على مفهوم حقوقها
يمتد لاسباب جذريه من العام 1979 مع
الاحتلال السوفيتي ورغم مضيء 40 سنه الا
ان الرهان اليوم يبقى على جيل اصغر من
الفتيات هن اقوى واكثروا وضوحا من النساء
الافغانيات اللاتي مهدنا لهن الطريق في
الماضي هذا جماعات وانا هدى الصالح
[موسيقى]